left ponomaryov was at least able to
secure his furniture and his files after
the moscow municipality threw him out of
his office it claims his lease had
expired ponomaryov denies that and says
the government was behind the eviction
it wants to silence critical voices what
ponomaryov does is advised citizens on
their rights the note he left on the
door says I will be back we are seeing a
downright hunt for human rights groups
they want to force us to declare that we
have foreign agents they are hunting us
down the two men who supervised the
eviction were extremely rough they said
you have sung your final song and now
we've got you we are going to do with
you whatever we want just google the
eviction a few days earlier was on the
news at a pro-kremlin television station
the crew arrived unannounced and were
anything but gentle seven of ponomaryov
colleagues were injured the 71 year-old
himself got a black eye and bruises all
over his body there was no court order
authorizing the eviction ponomaryov says
it was therefore illegal he appealed to
the Kremlin's Human Rights Commissioner
who said he would investigate are you
just vicious anymore it's true they
cannot do their work now because they
had to leave their office though but
it's hard to believe that that was the
aim of the Moscow municipality the whole
thing seems designed to cast the mayor
in a bad light in the city of scum
perimeter with me Thomas curry
nongovernmental organizations believe
that this campaign is focused on them as
hundreds of their premises have
undergone searches galos is a team of
election observers it receives funds
from abroad and that makes the NGO a
foreign agent under the law Gullas
refused to register as such so it has
been temporarily suspended
with Windows no bleep idiot look right
before the presidential election in
March last year we had to move offices
can you imagine what that means all our
phones all our documents and it is where
we worked with our volunteers we had
prepared everything for the election and
then they simply throw us out in utter
disregard of the law machine late 2011
and early 2012 saw a wave of
anti-government demonstrations the
authorities responded forcefully tens of
thousands of people gathered in the
heart of Moscow to call for freedom they
accused the authorities of election
fraud and demanded fresh elections
Gullas had identified numerous
irregularities in both parliamentary and
presidential elections at the time
Gullas received funds from organizations
in Europe and the United States Vladimir
Putin claimed the Americans wanted to
promote regime change in Russia and
reusing Russian NGOs to further that
goal many NGOs are refusing to register
as foreign agents as required by the
controversial law they do not see
themselves as spies or as acting for any
foreign power ponomaryov has taken the
issue to court he says he is not
politically active all he does is fight
for the rights of tenants conscripts and
prisoners he does not expect to win his
case western music is there is a clear
hierarchy in Russia state prosecutors
and judges have to implement decisions
taken right at the top and the powers
that be have long since decided that the
NGO should not win any of their court
cases what it for now ponomaryov and his
team can use the premises of another
human rights organization but they
cannot get down to work yet
left ponomaryov is defiant he insists he
is not a foreign agent and says he will
never sign a document saying so